[Music]
let's have a sort of
starting point here if you
believe allah darwin
that we are one among many species
on the planet that have been created by
evolution cosmic evolution
so in terms of the history of the
universe what
what do we want to say 13 billion years
and then let's say three or four billion
years ago
life arises on earth right
um there's a sense in which if you're
looking at homo sapiens
okay as a species that this is
a relatively recent development
right of course when we talk about homo
sapiens which is to say
and and i think it's really clear that
we get this straight the outset
homo sapiens is a way of identifying
human-like characteristics in apes
but the concept of humanity predated
that okay
so homo sapiens is actually a coinage of
the
18th century
okay no one was using this language
before then
and this is where the great swedish
botanist right uh linnaeus
carlos linnaeus you know gave this kind
of
a very structured way of understanding
all forms of life
on earth right animals
plants and also rocks actually right
giving them
what we now call in the
in the scientific literature across the
disciplines
binomial nomenclature
right two names that's all it means it's
a fancy latin way of talking about two
names
right binomial nomenclature homo sapiens
so
the homo part tells you it's part of the
eighth kingdom basically
and the sapience part says what is it
that distinguishes
us from all the other apes right
that is an innovation of the mid-18th
century okay now
before the 18th century people
nevertheless
for some strange reason had an idea of
what it meant to be human
how did they get that idea they hadn't
seen many apes
right i mean again you know we talk
and and this is where um
ethnocentrism might be helpful
okay the reason
you know all of this stuff that i've
been talking about up to this point
that has to do with the way in which we
define the human
even before we get to transhumanism has
been very much part
of western history right
um and western history as we all know
from all of our political correctness
courses
across the humanities and social
sciences is ethnocentric
and so we end up getting linnaeus only
in the
mid-18th century actually going through
the trouble of saying
that humans are some form of ape
well that has a lot to do with europeans
all of a sudden seeing a lot of apes
and seeing you know through colonization
and you know the conquests of the
latin america asia africa
all these places all of a sudden
europeans in the early modern period
through
all of these projects of exploration
start to
see all these creatures they've never
seen before and they're not in the bible
right whatever
right all of a sudden they kind of look
like us
yeah right and they even sort of act
like us and all the rest of it
right and so linnaeus the man who coins
homo sapiens is a creationist
but he are you know he's kind of
sensitive to empirical phenomena
right and and so he sees that all these
people from all these different parts of
the world
are all of a sudden saying look there
are a lot of creatures that look like
us they're out there they're called apes
they're all over the place and in fact
there's so much all over the place
we can't tell the difference between
apes and humans
which is actually about what a lot of
what most of the politically correct
people
are arguing about these days with regard
to what happened in the 15th 16th and
17th centuries
right because you couldn't tell the
difference between a native and an ape
they didn't look different enough
okay so the point is
nevertheless the idea of the human
pre-existed
all of this racist [ __ ]
right this is the point people
right so let's take that as the first
point
about transhumanism right that there is
a sense
that you have to think about the human
in a much more kind of abstract
conceptual kind of way
than the idea of a human corresponding
to a certain kind of ape
that is only something that starts to
get traction
in the mid 18th century with linnaeus
and of course
darwin see linnaeus is a creationist
right
linnaeus is a creationist who kind of
starts to believe his eyes
and says wow all these different
beings kind of look like humans at the
empirical morphological level
so we you know in a sense we may have
we may have some relationship to them
but god did something to
us and that is to say they put a soul
into us
right and this is where you start to
begin to get the kind of contemporary
disagreements between the creationists
and the darwinists right because because
linnaeus has already bought into
the ape story and so he's thinking eight
plus
what and when you get into the issue of
ape
plus what right then if someone has a
great explanation for how apes came
about
you're going to be screwed right because
you're going to have this alternative
history going on
that can explain age can explain all
sorts of animals how they came into
being and so forth
and then all this idea about the idea
that the
you know humans or apes with the
difference starts to kind of lose its
appeal
okay um and and this is a i
i just point this out at the outset
because i think if you were back
in the uh mid 18th century before
darwinism becomes dark dominant but
at the time at which you get a lot of
significant european
scientists and philosophers thinking
about
apes for the first time all of a sudden
coming on their shores and
you know being in zoos and museums and
you know
and all this kind of stuff right this
actually
changes in a very fundamental way the
way in which people were
thinking about what it means to be human
because if you look at the human
either in latin or greek or any of these
languages prior to the mid-18th
century they are not particularly
attached
to a particular physical embodiment
okay and you can go back to the ancient
greeks who are the most pagan people in
the world they have nothing to do with
christianity plato aristotle all these
guys
right where's the apes
where are these apes when they talk
about humanity and so forth
right then it's not there even if you
you know you look at someone
who is very sympathetic to animals
and thought animals were very wise you
look at
isab the fables right
you know about this right all these
fables right
um that that existed that that are kind
of very much part of our heritage today
right um you know the you know the the
ant and the grasshopper the fox and the
hedgehog all these things
where the apes where are the apes
they're not there right because
there's a sense in which the idea of the
human
at the early stages right in the greek
and roman world and i would say this is
true even
in the judeo-christian world was kind of
open-minded
with regard to the embodiment of what it
was to be human
this is the point i'm trying to bring
across and this is the point
that people who believe in transhumanism
call
morphological freedom
now what that means nowadays is a
different matter and i will probably
talk more about that in the second half
of the
of the talk but i just want to give you
the idea
that the the whole basic idea of what it
means to be
human
has not historically been tied
to being a certain kind of body and
being in a certain kind of body
in a certain kind of way to continue
watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas